yeah let's talk about these playoffs a
little bit man
the um well first of all uh
jokic got a flagrant two i love how
every time there's a flagrant uh youtube
called
twitter lights up and then like half the
people are like oh [ __ ] what they do
they can't do y'all are waiting for us
to get canceled
um but uh so basically he he fouls
kind of hard um pain what's the guy's
first name
cameron payne and uh
he gets a flagrant two and he gets
kicked out of the game he is the mvp
yeah
and the foul he doesn't even hit cameron
payne it looks like
maybe he like just does he swipes that
but he just brushes his face he's the
sitting mvp if lebron did that foul on
anybody he's not going anywhere
i don't even think they give him
flagrant one i think they just call foul
but he barely even touches him
and also it's cameron payne if joking
did that foul on cp3
if he did it against booker if he did
against someone who mattered then
okay i understand maybe a flagrant one
maybe yeah but cameron payne
yeah he's not changing the game in any
way no
so it's like he's a good player that's
it he's a good player if the suns
weren't whooping that ass already and if
it wasn't already a
3-0 lead i don't think that this is a
flagrant two
but i think they understood what was
happening in the series and they were
like
all right fine let's get him out of here
but it's weird that he didn't get the
preferential treatment it would bother
you be the leak
it bothers me this is the mvp there
should be preferential treatment yeah
you got to keep your stars in the game
and i don't mind like
that in and of itself everybody gets
treated equally but the precedent has
been set throughout my entire lifetime
stars get preferential treatment yeah so
it bothers me that all of a sudden this
guy
gets ejected from a game but i don't
think most players would get ejected for
this foul flagrant one maybe
flagrant blows my [ __ ] mind yeah was
going for the ball
he did hit his face and that's part of
the flagrant call
but i think what made it bad is that he
got in motherfucker's face afterwards
uh devin booker ran across and got in
his face and he yeah but then he was
like going
to so it's like it's like if you get the
tech and you know you got the flagrant
like just chill but the fact that he
tried to now
almost instigate a fight that's why they
were like now you're out here yeah we
gotta get you out of here yeah
i don't know it is interesting though
what's happening with
uh cp3 yes because i'm sure we've said
plenty of times on this podcast
he's just not good enough to get it done
his body his body won't let him his body
won't let him
and we might have even said he's not
good enough to get it to get it done if
he wins the championship
this year he erases any criticism
everything is different
it is unbelievable and we've said on
this podcast what he needs
is a beta score
yes and i don't know if devin booker's
beta because he seems like a pretty
alpha player but
i think he's fine with just going out
there getting buckets and then letting
cp3 manage the rest of the team
yes and i think the cp3 respects booker
he's like yo this guy gets buckets i can
pass him the ball and he's gonna knock
down these tough shots
and i think we even said on the podcast
we're like yeah he needs a kd
and it's like well yeah who doesn't need
a kd but devin booker was not looked at
as one of the top five players in the
league
but now that cp3 and him are on the same
team and booker's putting up these big
[ __ ] numbers i guess they're locking
down offensively
you're starting to see how absolutely
amazing
cp3 is as cp3 is at managing a team
and making a deep run in the playoffs
you know i think devin booker and cb3
works
devon booker's 13 years younger so it's
a whole different like blake griffin was
younger but what like four or five years
yeah they felt like they're in the same
generation
i mean you're not gonna say you're like
i'm not gonna see you look up to you
you're four or five years older than me
13 years of big [ __ ] gap
like you watched him play ball growing
up you got to emulate him yeah 73 came
into the league oh
20. so you were seven yeah so you watch
this guy you've seen how good he is you
look up to him and now he's on your team
you're like oh that's a guy i want to
emulate
this eb3 if you're into being like him
yeah absolutely
i just need to make sure you want to win
i'm gonna ride you pretty hard but if
you're 13 years younger than me is tough
love
if you're my age it's like yo who the
[ __ ] are you talking to yeah
are you crazy like i'm even if i'm james
harden i'm what
six years younger or whatever but it's
like bruh i'm a [ __ ] mvp [ __ ] you
i don't care if you're four or five
years older 13 years ah this is tough
love
this is coaching it's a father son big
brother little brother thing whatever it
is
so i think that's the main reason and
like you said i think devin booker just
wants to be a scorer and he's
fine being a [ __ ] killer scorer yeah
and that's it and then you can make me
more complete
player but like you manage the game i'll
get it and most importantly manage the
team
yeah like you manage all the guys get
them motivated make sure they're staying
doing what they're supposed to do and i
don't have to do that i just have to get
buckets yep
like for a guy who likes to score and it
seems like that's
all he likes to do that's the dream yeah
yeah i mean it's tough to take every
shot
for your team not every shot but like
it's tough to take the majority of shots
for your team and then yell at a
[ __ ] for not getting back on d
right when that guy wants to touch the
rock too but now the guy who's yelling
at you to get back on d
is the guy who didn't just shoot yeah
yeah yeah right
it's the guy who also passed the ball so
someone else could yes you might gotta
listen to that guy he's the guy who just
wants to run the offense
yeah it's not like you were talking
about another player who's like i want
to get the point or the assist
cp3 is like i want us to get the point
just trust me and we'll figure this [ __ ]
out
and it is looking very
likely that um
the suns could not play the nets but
maybe the bucks
yeah yeah that's sad i mean look at what
happens so
hardin goes down with the hamstring
injury it looks like he might not even
play this series
i wouldn't think so hamstring is usually
a nagging injury nagging injury takes a
little while
kyrie turns the ankle yeah badly
badly turns the ankle so he's gonna be
limited maybe not come back until who
knows
game six maybe game seven if they can
push yeah
and pj tucker for whatever reason is
doing a great job
yeah on kd i think he held katie
scoreless in the fourth quarter
that's wild that's crazy and nobody's
having this conversation about it which
is quite interesting
yeah but katie not scoring in the fourth
quarter of a playoff game when he's the
only guy
on the team that's out there that's
there to score that's tricky
yeah bucks take two in a row it's going
back to brooklyn
but still it's kd by himself pretty much
yeah i mean no disrespect to the other
players on the team but we're talking
when you talk about the big three
we know exactly who the [ __ ] we're
talking about so
because of these circumstances not
because of the talent because the
circumstances
is looking like the bucks could get out
of there which is unreal
because you never thought that was gonna
happen after the first two games nope
they could actually skate by and who the
[ __ ] knows what happens after that
they play philly that's not a i think
philly's a crazy hard game
for the bucks you got two guys the two
best players on both teams possibly
i guess embiid's better but ben simmons
can't shoot giannis can't shoot
that kind of offsets each other you know
usually if there's one player that can't
shoot you just play off of him and then
you're four on five and everything's
different
you've got two teams playing for them
yeah it's four and four yeah i mean like
i
i'm not i'm not that scared of philly if
i'm the bucks i am scared of brooklyn
with a healthy big three yeah terrified
but the thing about kyrie doug he's
always [ __ ] hurt and i didn't think
it would matter because harden
was an iron man and durant when he he
has either crazy injuries or no injuries
or none yeah
it's really interesting to see and then
it's also now you got to be a little
concerned about katie's health because
if katie's got to carry that team yes
he's rest of the achilles
yeah but you don't know what type of
other entries are just kind of lingering
and because you get to take some plays
off
you don't put that type of pressure on
it but now that you're going to be the
focal point of that offense
and you're going to be going hard
against a guy who's been busting his ass
playing d
on you you never know what could happen
i would not be surprised if a kd injury
pops up in the next couple games
i mean you you can only there's a limit
to what you can put your body through
yeah and he's gonna have to surpass that
limit to carry the team yeah
i think it's the most brooklyn way to do
it you get all the heat everybody's all
about brooklyn
yeah it's just such a brooklyn way to
handle it and all the tension is on you
and then you get so close but somehow it
just gets [ __ ] up in the end [ __ ] up
you ready to be the borough
and somehow it just gets [ __ ] up in
the end after the first two games people
thought they were going to sweep
i know they go from they beat their ass
i know and now [ __ ]
and they were up one with seven seconds
left in game three they win that game
who gives a [ __ ]
kyrie can come back for a game seven
even if he turns his ankle yeah so he
gives a [ __ ]
but they lost that game because drew
holiday had this nice little
game-winning spinning layup
and then that changed everything k.d
came damn close on a great shot like
hard shot
if they win that game the series is over
they lose that game
in the final seven seconds now they get
blown out here and kyrie is hurt
and they might lose two more after this
maybe and now everything is different
you